the next three hours is your chance to
talk with author and professor Randall
Kennedy the former law clerk to Justice
Thurgood Marshall will talk about race
politics and the Obama administration
the Rhodes Scholar is the author of five
books including the controversial [ __ ]
the strange career of a troublesome word
and his 2011 relief the persistence of
the color line racial politics and the
Obama presidency
Harvard professor Randall Kennedy in
your best-selling book the n-word the
strange career of a troublesome word you
write about violence by speech woody
mean well that book is about the word
[ __ ] and it is itself a word that has
triggered lots of violence and to some
it's a violent word in and of itself and
what I wanted to do in that book was to
give a history of this word that has
been covered with blood literally and
sometimes figuratively and wanted to
show the way in which this word has
wrought havoc in American culture of
course that's not all it does one of the
reasons why it was book worthy is
because it's a complicated word it has a
terrible history history of insult a
history of terrorism a history of
intimidation but of course it's been put
to other uses too it's been put to
anti-racist uses it's been made an
ironic term it has been made a term of
endearment so the word [ __ ] is a
complicated word it has its violent
aspects but it has other aspects as well
who was Big Mama and how did she use the
word ahhh Big Mama was Lillian Spann a
wonderful lady who probably did not get
more than a sixth grade education born
in South Carolina lived her entire life
in South Carolina she was a seamstress
she she was a domestic she was a
strong-willed lady who raised a slew of
kids sent most of them through college
an absolutely great person I knew her uh
for a good portion of my life she
I used a whole lot of different words
she referred to black people sometimes
as colored people but she also sometimes
would use the infamous n-word and she's
been a person who's example and whose
wisdom has been with me all my life is
it illegal to use the n-word
generally speaking no although well I
take it I take that back
if you use the n-word in an employment
setting for instance if you are
somebody's supervisor and you refer to
your work to a worker as a [ __ ] or you
refer to black people as [ __ ] you may
be in violation of the law by creating a
hostile workplace and thereby make
yourself subject to liability under
state law or under the civil rights law
of 1965 1964 so under certain
circumstances you can do things which
would make yourself which would subject
yourself to leave a liability or another
way if you um if you commit violence and
in the commission of a violent act refer
to people using the n-word you might be
subject to hate law legislation and
thereby not only be prosecuted for
assault or you know whatever violent act
you've committed but you might subject
yourself to an enhanced penalty by
running afoul of state hate laws so
under certain circumstances yeah you
would be in violation of the law um
generally speaking though because of the
strong shielding power of the First
Amendment people for instance
comedians or writers can use the n-word
and not have to fear the law though you
might have to fear a public-opinion
which itself can be a very powerful
force is that the mere words versus
fighting words argument that you were
making earlier about that word well in
the law of the law of homicide there are
all sorts of different levels of
homicide and one big divide is between
manslaughter and second-degree murder
so for manslaughter the law gives you a
little if you kill someone but you can
make the argument that you killed
somebody if you were in the grip of
passion but the classic example of
manslaughter is you come home and you
find your girlfriend or you're fine your
wife in the arms of another and you kill
that person you've committed a violent
acts but the law will give you a little
bit of a break because you were in the
grip of passion and the law says we give
you something of an excuse not a full
excuse but we recognize that you
couldn't control yourself well there's
been some people who made the argument
that they were in the grip of passion
because somebody called them the
infamous n-word they strike the person
maybe they kill the person and the
argument becomes can you or can your
lawyer make the argument to a jury that
you were in the grip of passion because
this person called you this particular
word now in some jurisdictions like
Washington DC you cannot even make that
argument Washington DC is a jurisdiction
that has the just words doctrine and the
law says no matter what the word no
matter what somebody called you that is
no excuse for using violence but other
jurisdictions say no we'll let you make
that argument to a jury professor
Kennedy you write
in the n-word book there is nothing
necessarily wrong with a white person
saying the n-word just as there is
nothing necessarily wrong with a black
person saying it what should matter is
the context in which the word is spoken
the speaker's Ames affects alternatives
to condemn whites who use the n-word
without regard to context is simply to
make a fetish of the word yes so the
best example to illustrate that point is
Mark Twain's great novel Huckleberry
Finn
[ __ ] appears in Huckleberry Finn over
200 times now I think Huckleberry Finn
is a wonderful novel and its impulse is
anti-racist its impulse is anti-slavery
obviously over the years there'd been
many people who have wanted the book
banned or have wanted to erase the word
I'm not for that here you have a white
author but he's using the book the the
term [ __ ] of for purposes that are
clearly anti-racist purposes there are
others Lenny Bruce Lenny Bruce was a
great social satirist he had a number of
skits in which he used the word [ __ ]
not to insult black people uh but rather
to turn the tables on racist anti people
who were anti black in their feeling and
he used the word [ __ ] to laugh at them
he was using the word [ __ ] as a a
mirror on racism in order to combat
racism so those are those are some
examples there others Eudora Welty use
[ __ ] in some of her novel some of her
short stories she wasn't using it to to
be a racist rather she was using it as
an artist to be legitimate racism so
that's what I meant by that term
obviously they're black people to who
have used the term [ __ ] in ways that
in my view are completely
unobjectionable get Gregory I titled his
first autobiography [ __ ] in
autobiography of course it was Richard
Pryor with two great albums that
nigger's crazy and Bicentennial [ __ ]
again using the term in anti racist ways
ironic ways when you decided to write
that book it was published in 2002 what
was the reaction you got from from
colleagues at Harvard Law publishers
well when I wrote that book I got a very
strong reaction of much of it positive
but also I got a lot of negative
reaction and I continued to get positive
reactions and negative reactions some
people took real offense at the title if
there was one aspect of the book that
probably got me the most negative
reactions it was people who complained
about the title and who thought that I
that I was being sensationalist who
thought that I was exploiting this term
by putting it right there in the title
right there on the the cover of a book
that would appear in you know bookstores
all across America
and what I said to people was and I
still say and I say this
unapologetically if you write a book you
want people to read your book there are
thousands of books in any bookstore
there are hundreds of thousands of books
in any big library and you told you got
a lot of competition the first thing
that you want to do if you're an author
is to at least have somebody pick up the
book and so when I was thinking of a
title I was thinking well what can I
title this book they would at least get
somebody to just take a peek read that
first paragraph and I thought well
[ __ ] [ __ ] the strange career of a
troublesome word I thought that would
stand
out and just like writers think hard
about topic sentences think hard about
words think hard about examples you know
get the reader's attention that's what I
was trying to do with this title and
it's certainly succeeded in getting
people's attention in 2008 you published
sellout the politics of racial betrayal
what's a sellout a sellout is a person
who is viewed as being a traitor to his
group and every group creates boundaries
every group has a notion of who's inside
the group and who's outside the group
and so every group has cells I mean the
United States of America has a law of
treason and if you do certain things
which are deemed to give comfort give
aid to an enemy of the United States you
make yourself subject to being called a
traitor being called a sellout if you're
taking money for it particularly so
every group has this and I wrote this
book to focus on this phenomenon in the
context of black Americans just like
like I say every group has this notion
of insiders and Outsiders therefore
every group has a notion that if you're
an insider and you do certain things
against the perceived interests of the
group what do we call these people we
call these peoples sellouts and that's
what I wanted to write about with the
possible exception of athletes you write
professor Kennedy blacks who attained
success in a multiracial setting will
always sooner or later encounter
whispered ensue insinuations or shouted
allegations that their achievement is
attributable at least in part to selling
out yes I'm sure that's true so for
instance there are some people
fortunately not many but there are some
african-americans friends
since we would call the first black
president a sellout there are black
Americans who will say that if if you're
black and you're the head of a fortune
500 company you're necessarily a sellout
there is a real anxiety within a
substantial part of black America when
confronting black Americans who are
successful in the wider society because
there's this anxiety that to be
successful especially if you're in a
predominantly white setting to get the
backing of white people to get the trust
of white people what do you have to do
to get that backing what did you have to
do to get that trust what did you have
to do to get that recognition there's
this fear that one of the things that
you had to do was to betray in some form
your community and that's that's what I
talk about good afternoon and welcome to
book TV on c-span 2 this is our monthly
in-depth program where we have one
author on to talk about his or her body
of work this month it's Harvard Law
Professor Randall Kennedy who has
written five books here are his books in
1997 he came out with race crime in the
law 2002 the N word the strange career
of a troublesome word interracial
intimacy's came out in 2003 sellout in
2008 and his most recent book the
persistence of the color line professor
when did you start teaching at Harvard I
started teaching it at Harvard in 1984
summer of 1984 what do you teach I teach
contracts I teach courses on race
relations law I have taught courses on
the First Amendment and criminal law but
nowadays it's really two courses
contracts and my race relations law
courses and if you would like to
participate in our conversation with
Professor Kennedy we're going to put the
numbers up on the screen 2:02 is the
area code 737
I'm sorry two oh two six two four eleven
seven thirty-seven triple zero one if
you live in the East or central time
zone it wasn't sure what numbers were
using sorry about that seven
thirty-seven triple zero two for those
of you in the mountain and Pacific time
zones and if you want to send an email
to Professor Kennedy you can at book TV
at c-span org or a tweet book TV slash
I'm sorry twitter.com slash book TV I
just got all that mixed up tonight when
we've done that once or twice in your
most recent book the persistence of the
color line racial politics in the Obama
administration you write that opposition
to anti black racism generates
protectiveness even blacks who
vehemently disagree with Obama on
important matters subordinate their
misgivings out of a sense that racial
loyalty demands solidarity with the
nation's first black president yes there
are people who are critical of the
president with respect to various issues
who have to make a calculation over and
over and over again whether they want to
publicize their criticism on the one
hand they have real disputes with the
president therefore want to relay their
you know their disappointment or their
disagreement to him and to others on the
other hand they recognize that the
President of the United States Barack
Obama is going to be facing opposition
not so much based in an authentic
disagreement with this or that policy
but rather an opposition that is fueled
by anti black racism and people even if
they are critical of President Obama do
not want to do anything that will help
the cause of those who are against the
president at least in part because he's
black what is a race man a race man race
man is a term that refers
two black Americans who have a sense of
camaraderie have a sense of solidarity
have a sense that they should use their
gifts their talents their resources not
only to further themselves but to uplift
the race with themselves it's an
honorific term to be a race man or a
race woman is to be a person who has a
sense of group responsibility in
sell-out the politics of racial betrayal
you write as a Justice Clarence Thomas
is very much a race man
by which I mean a black person who seeks
self-consciously to advance by his own
lights the interests of African
Americans yes now you know when you
write a book one thing about writing
books is that you do the best you can at
a particular point but sometimes you
want to revise things and frankly this
is what you just read is a sentence that
I would probably not write again if I
were if I were redoing that book I would
revise that sentence what I meant to say
when I wrote that was that Clarence
Thomas is a person whose politics are at
variance with most black Americans
strongly at variance with most black
Americans and he's very conservative
most black Americans in terms of
politics are not but he does in his own
view see himself as pushing a political
agenda that will in his view advance the
fortunes of black Americans and that's
that's what i meant by in his own in his
own mind he sees himself as a race man i
think it's in certain ways i would still
I think that's a
portrayal of the Justice I think I get
when I wrote that I was being rather
generous though I think that if I were
revisiting that territory I would be
more critical of the justice because
frankly in the way in which he has not
only taken positions but also voice the
positions that he's taken I think that
there is I have now more questions than
I had then of the degree to which he
sees himself as someone who has
obligations to advance the portions of
black Americans where did you grow up
where to go to school I I was born in
Columbia South Carolina in 1954
September 10th 1954 I spent my first few
years of life in Columbia South Carolina
but in but at a young age my parents
left South Carolina they were refugees
from the Jim Crow South and they moved
to Washington DC in search for more
opportunity and I grew up and well here
in Washington DC I went to the public
schools for a good long while I went to
Tacoma elementary school and then I went
to Paul jr. high school and then I went
to st. Albans school for boys and st.
Albans is a private school in the
grounds of the National Cathedral st.
Albans was a formative influence for me
st. Albans school was probably the most
influential school that that I attended
why well
well for one thing it at st. Albans I
learned the rudiments of expository
writing and so anytime I write an
article in time I write a book I quite
literally
a thank you to my teachers in st. Albans
I think of I think a Ferdinand Eluga who
taught a wonderful class on expository
writing I think of Charles Saltzman I
think of mr. Willis I think most
importantly of my high school history
teacher John F McCune who introduced me
to history introduced me to the study of
history the study of historical writing
historiography very important figure in
my intellectual development how many
African Americans attended that school
and you were there not many in my
graduating class of 70 there were
probably seven black American students
when I began st. Albans that were fewer
but more came over time so they weren't
there were not that many they're the
more now but when I was there there were
not many black students it was a
extraordinary intellectual environment
absolutely extraordinary the st. Albans
really did inculcate a notion of public
mindedness we debated it said Albans all
of the public issues of the day there
was a wide range of ideological
positions that people took we were
encouraged to speak out you're
encouraged to write down our views and
to this day I have very fond feelings
toward st. Albans and again very fond
feelings towards toward my teachers
Princeton I went to Princeton University
between 1973 and 1977 again a wonderful
experience I
think again of just a host of teachers
um several of whom had become very close
friends of mine one of my teachers at
the at Princeton was a man by the name
of Sanford Levinson Sanford Levinson
University of Texas on the University of
Texas a very distinguished very
interesting intellectual in general the
legal academic I had him for full up to
politics in fact I had him for a course
on constitutional interpretation at
Princeton he gave me my lowest grade at
Princeton
we had been lifelong friends ever since
oh he's read he reads he's read all of
my books in manuscript form always gives
me wonderful feedback at Princeton James
McPherson the great historian of the
Civil War was my thesis advisor one of
my teachers at Princeton was a visiting
professor Eric Foner the great American
historian Columbia now he's at Columbia
my senior at my senior thesis was a
biography of Richard Hofstadter Richard
Hofstadter had been Eric Foner's
dissertation adviser Eric Foner is now
the DeWitt Clinton professor at Columbia
Richard Hofstadter had been the DeWitt
Clinton professor at Columbia and I've
known Eric for decades now he too is a
person who reads all my work gives me
feedback so Princeton is a school I
meant on the board of trustees of
Princeton I have very fond feelings
toward Princeton it too very influential
in in my life about ten years after you
were there Michelle Obama attended
Princeton heard didn't seem her
experience was the same as yours I but
my sense is from what I've read in the
paper that she did not have as positive
an experience as me I'm sorry about that
my experience was very positive
and again I I feel lucky in that way I
mean I've been a lucky person with my
associations I feel absolutely
extraordinarily blessed at every stage
of my life I've interacted with people
who have been encouraging who had been
supportive starting of course with my
parents my father Henry Kennedy has
passed away my mother Rachel Kennedy is
alive my mother was a schoolteacher
my parents were deeply invested in
education I'm an older brother of a
younger sister my parents deeply
invested in our in our education nothing
took precedence over education in our
household they were supportive they sent
me to schools that as I've already
indicated were just tremendously
supportive I have been lucky enough to
fall under the sway of wonderful
teachers at every institution I've
attended and indeed again I mean I've
had wonderful I've met friends along the
way but at every school that I've
attended since high school some of my
very closest friends have been my
teachers you write in the year-end word
book about the first time when you came
home from the playground and related to
your parents that you'd been called the
n-word and got different reactions from
mom and dad I did the first time I don't
really remember the first time I heard
the infamous in word it probably goes so
far back I mean it's a word that been
around me all my life but the first time
I got in a fight over the n-word was
when a little white boy called me [ __ ]
at recess at Combe elementary school and
we fought after school and I came home
and I remembered dinner my hair
to ask me you know how was school today
you know what happened at school today
and I just relate to them I said well
everything was perfectly fine but this
kid called me [ __ ] at the recess and
we had to fight afterwards and my
parents had completely different
reactions with my father saying yeah you
did the right thing and you know from
you you can if somebody calls you [ __ ]
you can fight them you have my
permission my mother on the other hand
thought that that was absolutely
ridiculous that what you should do is
recognize that anybody who calls you
that word meaning to insult you is just
a stupid person and you should ignore
them and in my book I talk about that I
focus on that episode to show the way in
which we do have a choice in terms of
the way in which we respond to symbols
in which we respond to words and frankly
over time although I've followed both
pieces of advice at various points in my
life over time I think that my mother
had the better of that argument well
we're going to start our conversation
with our viewers with an email and this
is from Byard pigeon Peter and professor
Kennedy please please say the N word not
the N word when anyone hears the N word
they automatically think that word so
why not avoid the extra syllables and
awkwardness of that stupid phrase the
book TV audience is I believe in hope
knowledgeable enough to not think every
use of the n-word is racist and somehow
beyond the pale of decency I find the
n-word much more offensive than that
word and you write about that in I do I
do
I um I use the term as you've already
seen I say [ __ ] but I also sometimes
say in word and I do not object when
people use the term in word there is
such a thing as euphemism we do
hover up certain facts with euphemisms
and I see a role for that too so I do
not I differ with the call or I do not
get angry when there are sufferings if I
have friends I have very good friends
who as a matter of just principle never
say the term [ __ ] they just never say
it and they never say it because to them
this word is so horrible it has wrought
so much havoc it has created so much
pain that in their view this is a matter
of principle they never say it and I
obviously I just I don't you know follow
that myself but I think that that's a
perfectly understandable position to
take and so I don't object when people
use the euphemism in word sometimes I
use it sometimes I do but I want to
thank mr. pigeon for his email and I
choose not to use it in sellout have you
ever had that word directed at you
though yes I've had the word directed I
had the word directed at me when I wrote
the book [ __ ] there were some people
who said that I was selling out for book
sales that the bat itself was a
politically irresponsible act that was
basically exploitative and that
therefore I was showing insufficient
racial loyalty in naming my book [ __ ]
so that's an example and other positions
I've taken in my academic career have
prompted people sometimes to label me a
sellout and as I indicate my book I've
been very fortunate I've been extremely
privileged in in my life I mean you know
I'm a professor at Harvard Law School a
very privileged position and there's
some people who look at that and presume
that
to attain that position I have had to
compromise my principles and engage in
various forms of racial betrayal so to
answer your question yes that is a term
that has been directed at me and I'm
quite sure that that was one of the
reasons why I wanted to write a book
about it in order to you know grapple
with that part of my autobiography when
you hear the term post-racial what do
you think
post-racial I don't say it's something
of a blur it's it's a it's a word that
has become you know rather popular I
don't use it I mean I know it's it's a
word that's out there if I use it I
usually put quotation marks around it
because it's not altogether clear to me
what it means I suppose that maybe it
means a society in which racial
consciousness has withered away perhaps
that's what people have in mind it seems
to me that it's a word which if it's to
be used profitably means more definition
so it seems to me that if one is going
to use the word one should probably
define rather clearly what one means by
it when I hear it it's one of those blob
words which it can mean most anything
and I sort of steer away from it in your
2003 book interracial intimacy's you
write I myself am skeptical skeptical of
if not hostile toward claims of racial
kinship the valorisation of racial roots
and politics organized around concepts
of racial identity I am a liberal
individualist who yearns for a society
in which race has become obsolete as a
significant social marker yeah it's
interesting you are picking portions of
my books which again this is another one
I think I would probably revise when I
wrote that I was I believed what I said
and basically when I wrote that book
I was in a very strongly individualistic
mode allergic to notions of group
responsibility group solidarity and
that's still a part of my persona I
don't think I would write that sentence
again though I I mean I I'm conflicted I
have strongly individualistic aspects
but I also am a race man I also am a
person who feels a I do feel feelings of
racial kinship and racial responsibility
and racial solidarity and um that is
something of a struggle within me and
within my writing and I think that when
I wrote that I I was I was actually
minimizing the solid eristic the race
man aspects of myself I think if I were
redoing it I would probably I would
probably be clear about the way in which
I'm conflicted I'm conflicted and in
some contexts I push further in one
direction and in some contexts I push
further in another but both of those
impulses are very much with me you
mentioned the book interracial
intimacy's that's one of my favorite
books one of the reasons why it's one of
it's in fact it's probably my favorite
book and one of the reason why it's
probably my favorite book is because I
have gotten more letters and emails from
people who've expressed gratefulness
about that book than probably any other
and the reason why
people have expressed gratefulness
because there's a big chunk of that book
that has to do with adoption and the
question there was a legal question that
was on the table when I wrote that book
and that the legal question was should
the legal system on in any way
discourage interracial adoption and I
took the very strong position that no
the legal system should not discourage
interracial adoption the legal system
should not privilege same race adoption
at all I took the position that what we
should want to do is to encourage
adoption and adoption of all sort is
something that seems to me that should
be encouraged there should be absolutely
no privilege of same race adoption over
interracial adoption and over the years
have been many many people who have
written and who have said that you know
this particular book gave them either
solace comfort encouragement the book
has been used in legal briefs and so in
that way my sort of individualism is
coming out you know what we should want
is youngsters to be brought up by loving
people forget about you know the race
thing let's just have loving adults
bring up children and I still believe
that very strongly very strongly at the
same time in other contexts am i a race
man yeah I'm a race man so if we're
talking about you know the Montgomery
bus boycott it's very easy for me to get
quite emotional in talking about the
greatness of the black people of
Montgomery Alabama
in what was an extraordinary instance of
community solidarity banding together to
create one a great moment in American
history and indeed world history so do I
have tensions within me that I work out
through my books or that I'm attempting
to work out through my books
yes can white people be race men sure
why people can do a race min and say
much of the history of the United States
is white people being race then Thomas
Jefferson was very much of a race man
Ben Franklin was very much of a race man
the fact Andrew Jackson was strong race
man and in fact that's a good question
you ask because they're you know they're
in a sense you have I'm brought face to
face with my new would be the ugly side
of being a race man words that some of
the great people and the history of
American statesmanship white race men
was John C Calhoun or a slanty yes he
was and we are the worse off because of
it um I guess I would yeah you know make
a distinction race man for what purpose
race man for what purpose so do I
embrace all blacks who are race men no
no I don't so if you or a race person of
whatever race and your aim is just to
institutionalize the superiority of your
group am I for that no am I for that was
up with it with a black face no so am i
a race man that wants black racial
superiority no I'm not numb no I'm not
that I'm a race man that wants to use
sentiments of racial solidarity to
create a just society for all people so
I guess I'm a transitional race man I'm
a race man strategically I'm a race man
that wants to create a cosmopolitan
society that one day actually would see
the withering away of racial
consciousness so I'm a transitional race
man Randall Kennedy is our guest Harvard
Law Professor author of five books race
crime in the law the n-word the strange
career of a troublesome word interracial
intimacy's came out in 2003 sellout in
2008 and his most recent is the
persistence of the color line which came
out last year Tanisha in Hampton
Virginia you've been very patient go
ahead with your question or comment for
professor Kennedy good morning I would
like to ask what black authors that he
recommend whose works focused on
cultural and political aspects authors
such as Amos Wilson shake ant idea
John Henry Clark even Vance Surma and 19
Akbar and then also I want him to
explain on an argument that the
advancement of the civil rights movement
of the 60s and the subsequent Brown
versus the Board of Education decision
did obvi the argument that it had more
to do with the damage of black
independence economically and
economically and culturally because it
took away from the ability of blacks to
control their own social structures in
their communities because before that
the communities were more established
and punctual okay I'll take those
questions in reverse order
I think it's profoundly mistaken to
believe that black Americans
were better off before the the civil
rights revolution I've heard people say
that it seems to me that sort of a
segregation nostalgia black Americans
are better off after the wonderful civil
rights revolution people forget the
degree to which segregation not only
involved a white supremacy excluding
blacks from various forums in American
life but how segregation also involved
putting black institutions under the
foam of some black people who were
themselves under the thumb of white
supremacist so for instance in the law
if one takes a look at the law of
student expression some of the classic
court cases that validate the notion
that students at public institutions
have free speech rights where do they
come from they came from black
institutions in the age of segregation
in which black principals or black
college presidents at the behest of
their white bosses through black kids
out of school and oppressed them
surpress them and we've you know a lot
of people have forgotten that a lot of
people have forgotten the way in which
during the age of segregation
black entrepreneurs would take you know
black customers for granted because
black customers were essentially a
captive market segregation was a
thoroughly evil system and we should not
in any sense
rooo it's passing black Americans today
are undoubtedly better off than they
were 50 years ago if we think about
symbolism and I think symbolism is very
important you might say that sitting at
the back of the bus was a matter of
symbolism in certain way it was I mean
if you're on a bus you know everybody's
going to the bus is getting it their
place at the same time did it make a
difference whether you had to sit at the
back of the bus as a way of showing that
you were lesser than white people yeah
that was a symbolism that made a lot of
difference we don't have that today we
have problems today I'm not saying that
we don't we have massive problems today
it is still the case that with respect
to any index of well-being whether we're
talking about life expectancy whether
we're talking about health and outcomes
whether we're talking about wealth
whether we're talking about income
whether we're talking about education
whether we're talking about
incarceration rates people of color and
in particular black people are still
getting the short end of the stick
that's true that's absolutely true but
as compared to a hundred years ago as
compared to 70 years ago as compared to
fifty years ago as compared to thirty
years ago black Americans have come a
long way it's a tribute to black
Americans it's a tribute to American
society as a whole it's an absolutely
extraordinary thing that as I sit
talking today the President of the
United States is a black American the
Voting Rights Act of 1965 1965 is not
long ago as as recently as 1965 there
were parts of the United States where
black people could not vote because of
in some instances sheer terror or other
instances just out-and-out fraud or
out-and-out just legal shiki Nury that
has changed we have a black president
the United States we have a black
Attorney General of the United States
and one could go on and on and on so
obviously for my statement I am not at
all
I'm hostile to the view that black
people have in any sense going backward
no black people have to their prep and
again the credit of all Americans to the
credit of American democracy has
advanced and had advanced in an
absolutely extraordinary way
now we with respect to the the first
question I recognize and have read some
of the authors that were referred to
those authors are not the authors that I
have relied upon in my work or that I
have taken inspiration from the authors
the the people who have written about
african-american culture over the years
who have most deeply influenced me would
be people like WB Dubois would be people
like Benjamin Quarles John Hope Franklin
those would be the the authors who I
think the the black American authors who
have had the biggest imprint on me
intellectually this is book TV on c-span
- this is our monthly in-depth program
Randall Kennedy is our guest and this
email has come in for you professor
Kennedy by Freda Williams of Albany
California why have previous attempts at
achieving reparations for blacks in the
past failed such as Randall Robinson's
attempt as outlined in his book the debt
and please give me your thoughts on the
possibility of a massive state
intervention that would consist of
building strong health educational and
good living conditions with a sustained
focus on black inner cities as well as
rural areas
the reparations story is a complicated
one on one hand the American Society has
been quite allergic to any talk of
reparations and has very strongly
repudiated claims for reparations by the
way I think wrongly I think reparations
would be I'm for reparations but as it
stated as reparations black Americans
have not gotten them and that's not
going to change anytime soon why is that
the case there are a number of reasons
one reason is just ignorance of the
American past and ignorance of the
degree to which black Americans have
been oppressed in American society not
only informally but also by the state
apparatus when I say the state apparatus
I mean the states of the United States
and I mean the federal government the
federal government of the United States
both when it was the the the leading
force behind slavery and then after the
abolition of slavery a leading force
behind segregation the United States
government as a government act terribly
toward black Americans and the way in
which it acted terribly continues to
reverberate in our society after and you
know after World War Two there was a
state policy of governmental policy
United States policy to help people own
homes and a lot of the wealth of
Americans is lodged in their homes well
that didn't work out so well for black
Americans because of a formal policy
taken by the United States government
that influences black people and
influenced my family and so ignorant is
part of it denial is part of it many
white Americans are
extremely allergic to anything that
smacks at accusation of the sort that I
just lodged and that's you know and so
reparations in at one level has not
borne fruit
but we live in a complicated we live in
a complicated society there's another
way in which reparations in fact I think
has borne through and that is through
for instance affirmative action
affirmative action um the main motive
power behind affirmative action is as
far as I'm concerned repair Ettore
justice it is a type of reparations it
has not been packaged that way partly
for the reasons that I just indicated
there's this allergy to reparation so we
package affirmative action in all sorts
of other ways diversity or something
else but the real motive behind much of
what we refer to as affirmative action
is trying to make amends for the past I
think that you know so as I'm concerned
that is correct we have it made nearly
enough in terms of amends for the past
but to the extent we've made some amends
that's a good thing will we in the
foreseeable future have a more capacious
more powerful more frank reparations
policy of the sort that the caller
suggested no we won't have that in the
foreseeable future I think unfortunately
but now we won't have that in
interracial intimacy's professor Kennedy
you right I am ambivalent about the
continuation of racial affirmative
action programs they have performed a
great service but they do draw racial
lines a toxic activity that should be
avoided absent compelling arguments to
country yes this is the third time in
our conversation that you have focused
on a text which I would revise in fact
my next book the book I'm working on
really hard now was going to be a book
about affirmative action I'm willing to
turn in the manuscript at the end of the
summer I am a proponent of affirmative
action it's true his for a long time I
was a vet very ambivalent I was always I
think for it but I was very ambivalent I
was torn now I'm not so torn I'm for
affirmative action in a much stronger
way than I have been in the past I do
think it's true that in American life
when you use racial distinctions to
allocate things I do think that almost
inevitably there is going to be a toxic
effect there is going to be the
exacerbation of resentments so whenever
you allocate things along racial lines
are there going to be some negatives yes
there are going to be some negatives so
there you know there's there are going
to be some debits but I think with
respect to affirmative action the pluses
have over the past 30 years have way
outweighed the negatives and so on the
affirmative action front
I'm a considerably stronger proponent
now than I have been in the past
Ahmad in New Albany Indiana you're on
with professor Randall Kennedy please go
ahead yes the first question I have for
you sir is the the transitional race man
that you spoke of I would like to say
that I'm somebody like that and I wanted
to know if you thought the work of John
Rawls would help us move in that
direction I'm a middle Easterner I'm an
Arab
American and I'm a post 9/11 veteran and
my experience since I've been back in
while I was in was that we kind of
experienced some of the bad parts of the
race man kind of thing because the bad
aspects of that is that we kind of rank
which one which races are more important
which discriminations are worse and in
my situation african-americans in the
workplace and outside the workplace have
casually used epithets towards Middle
Easterners and you know with terrorist
type comments and things like that
and I wanted to get your views on that
and I really appreciate you working
thank you very much thank you very much
for calling
listen can black people be racist answer
yes and we've seen that frankly we've
seen that throughout American history
black people have participated in
terrible acts against Native Americans
black people have participated in
American imperialist ventures black
people today some unfortunately have
participated in the racist taunting
people of Middle Middle Eastern ancestry
black people are people and so you know
black people have done wonderful things
just like people of all backgrounds have
done wonderful things black people have
done terrible things just like people of
all backgrounds have done terrible
things and that's you know we seem to me
that that is a point that needs to be
underlined and when black people act out
at badly mistreat people act in a racist
way act in a misogynistic way
act in a way that shows disrespect for
people based on sexual orientation when
black people act out badly
everybody ought to call them out
including other black people now on your
thing about your comment about race men
I mean I you know I respect John Rawls
but frankly if I had to choose one
single person to grapple with this race
man idea the person I would choose will
be Martin Luther King Jr Martin Luther
King jr. also had a struggle within
himself there were times when he was the
race man of Montgomery bus boycott in
his first speech to grade speech first
speech as a civil rights champion in
announcing the boycott he talks about he
calls on black people to band together
so that when the history books were
written historians would talk about the
greatness of black people as a people he
was speaking very specifically as a race
man at the same time he was a
cosmopolitan person who at his best
recognized that we are all brothers and
sisters and should embrace one another
as brothers and sisters so I think that
Martin Luther King jr. himself is what I
would call a transitional race man and
insofar is trying to get one's bearings
in our complicated racial environment I
can't think of a better person than
Martin Luther King jr. not that he had
all the answers not that I agree with
him about everything but he certainly in
spirit I had a a wonderful spirit that
still very much inspires me our next
call comes from st. George Utah
go ahead Ron Ron you with us
last chance for Ron can you hear me
please go ahead with your question
yep yeah professor I wanted to ask you
about a sellout how would you view a
person who was a came to prominence
basically as a voice in the inner cities
and then was given a job and he danced
East to continue to be that voice are he
eradicated the major part in my opinion
of his rhetoric which was action it's
kind of like in the movie um I'm going
to get you sucker where they said well
what happened to all the brothers well
they gave them jobs well I can
understand that you know but this is a
person that came to prominence as a
voice of people of the inner cities and
then got a job and ceased to really be a
voice with action I think that your
colleague Cornel West confronted one
such person who now is on MSNBC I don't
know like say that but he confronted him
it's called him a sellout and actually
told him that well you haven't done
anything anyway how do you how do you
view such a person there now take it off
there okay thank you very much for the
for the call I think people ought to be
very careful when they use the sellout
label you know we all do things for all
sorts of reasons we have different
phases of our life let's take the
example that you just gave the person
who is in the inner city maybe as a
community activist then he gets a job
and you don't hear from them well have
to ask a whole lot of questions one
question I would want to know is is he
doing this strategically is he for
instance by
his time is he taking the position that
well I've been giving this job and given
this job maybe I will be quiet for a
while be quiet for a season or two or
three um get seniority get knowledge get
position and then later I will attempt
when I've got you know more power to do
things which I think I could not do now
now people say that all the time and you
know is it often times when people say
it
they're just rationalizing their
accommodation to new circumstances
they're just rationalizing their
quiescence they're bought quiescent so
that happens but sometimes it doesn't
happen and so you know I think we need
to be very careful before we say that
somebody is engaged in what we call
racial treason selling out do I think
that there are people who sell out yeah
I think they're people who sell out but
I want to be loose to come to that
conclusion I want to know a lot about
them I want to have real clear proof
before I call somebody a sellout and
from your book sellout professor Kennedy
you've mentioned the Montgomery bus
boycott a couple of times you write this
the boycott is typically portrayed as an
entirely voluntary enterprise in which
the heroes of the story waged their
struggle against racist villains without
morally soiling their hands at all the
reality however was considerably more
complicated the boycott was mainly
animated by the commitment of many
blacks to reform if not erase patterns
of racial subordination that they
rightly import' it is important to note
however that the boycott was also
reinforced by the knowledge that any
black person caught riding the buses
would face ostracism from his peers he
or she would be denounced as a sellout
or words to that effect yes
the things I wanted to point out in my
book is that again we're all part of
groups and whenever you're part of a
group a group creates boundaries and if
you wander far enough outside the
boundary the group is going to sanction
you the United States government has a
law of treason for instance that's a
nation state every group has its
boundaries and from time to time a group
will use coercion to good people into
shape every time for instance there is a
strike when there's a strike you know
Union called a strike somebody who Union
member who crosses the picket lines is
going to be ostracized that person is
going to be called a scab they're going
to be all sorts of coercive is when all
sorts of coercive force brought to bear
on that person to try to whip that
person into shape
now that's just a fact of collective
action and I've already indicated my
great admiration for the Montgomery bus
boycott of 1955-56 but was there a
coercive aspect to the boycott yes there
was there were some black people that
did want to ride the bus and you can
understand what they did and then you
know if you had to go you have to go
walk for five miles if you really needed
money ah to support your family and you
thought that you needed to get to your
workplace you might very well have been
willing to ride at the back of that bus
even if most of your black neighbors
took a different position well to make
that boycott effective word had to go
out that listen we as a community mean
business and if you cross the community
on this you will have to pay a very
steep price that is what comes with
collective action um
and you know just to be realistic about
it that's that's what comes uh you know
the United States of America when it
goes to war has a draft if you don't
submit to the draft and the
powers-that-be
say that you ought to you go to jail
again
collective action always as an aspect of
coercion surrounding it and that's one
of the features I talk about in my book
Robert in Atlanta you're on with author
and professor Randall Kennedy Thank You
professor I appreciate p.m. the
opportunity to ask you a question I was
I was actually struck by your your
comment about your parents in that I
think we live in a bit of a parallel
universe I had about 40 years ago
experienced something very similar when
coming home from school up to first
hearing that epithet and explaining it
to my father who's a wrist returned from
Vietnam and he had mentioned to me how
that was unacceptable to even stand by
and see that and as I returned the next
day with the bloody nose that resulted
from standing next to the young man had
received the first time my mother
explained to him that that was not the
best approach arrest advisors actually
then kicked me out for ice cream
so it's interesting how have two
different people from two different
areas could have such a similar result
from their parents but to my question
they're both about bias the first is how
media bias around conservatives and I'm
struck by how Thomas ol and Alan West
and Justice Kennedy are referred to by
the community and even in your example
so you mentioned President Obama and
Attorney General but but not Justice
Kennedy and injustice cons right around
the dichotomy of how a racial bias is
treated where it seems that the
african-american community has voted for
President Obama almost as a monolithic
bloc and yet when others disagree
regardless of race with some of those
policies they are often too often
regarded as doing so out of racial
prejudice
which really freezes the argument in its
place because short of being called a
pedophile in today's community being
called a racist is probably the worst
thing that you could be called in an
enlightened community which is what I
seek to be vicious bit of it thank you
sir okay well there are there are a
number of interesting points in your
comment with respect to President Obama
and the african-american community in my
book the persistence of the color line
one thing that I was very keen to recall
is that the President Obama had to work
awfully hard to get the African
community African American community on
his side remember early on in his
campaign many African American activists
and elected officials were in the camp
of his rival Hillary Clinton it was only
after Barack Obama won the Iowa caucus
and did well in some of the other
primaries and only after he really
worked hard to get African Americans on
his side the African American community
went for him it's true that black
Americans especially in presidential
politics overwhelmingly favor of the
Democratic candidate I don't think that
they are acting with a herd mentality I
don't think that they're acting but
under dead of brainwashing I don't think
that they are acting unthinkingly I
think that the great mass of black
Americans size up the candidates and
make a thoughtful decision about which
candidate is going to have policies that
on balance are going to best serve their
interests and I think that the great
mass of black Americans made up their
minds that Barack Obama and his policies
would would do that um with you
expect to your comment about the term
racist I agree with you it racist as it
is an interesting term it is a word an
idea that fortunately has been it's an
idea that it's highly stigmatizing in
American life especially if you're an
electoral politician you do not want to
be viewed as a racist and that's a good
thing I mean after all there was a time
not so long ago when politicians frankly
didn't care indeed they were probably
was the time not so long ago when some
politicians would have liked being
referred to as a racist that is no
longer the case and that's a good thing
ironically there is a flip side to that
racist has become such a stigmatizing
term that sometimes people are afraid to
use the term even when it fits because
if you use the term and then somebody
calls you on it and says well I don't I
don't agree why are you calling somebody
such-and-such a person a racist
it turns out that if you cannot give a
good persuasive reason for why you
called such-and-such a person or racist
then it flips and you become stigmatized
for having called the person such as
stigmatizing term and so sometimes now
in American life we've actually gone to
you know people don't say that so-and-so
is racist they say so-and-so is racially
insensitive or some other sort of
weaselly word because you don't want to
be caught out calling somebody a racist
and then not be able to persuasively
back up your your claim so it's an
interesting word it's probably a word
that could stand a book in your nearly
thirty years of teaching have you run
across students who you've determined
are racist I've had a few um very few
very
whew but have you been a couple yeah
there been a couple but but I say very
few you know one of the great again I've
been so privileged in my life I earlier
about the association's I've had with
respect to family with respect to
friends with respect to with respect to
colleagues with respect to teachers my
teacher with my students I mean all of
the books that are right are tried out
on my students we have these things we
have these captive audiences called
classes and in my classes I try out my
books and my students respond and give
me great feedback which I put to use
when I you know in rewriting and
rewriting and rewriting these
manuscripts and my students have been
just wonderful in terms of helping me to
put together the books I have students
from a wide range of ideological
positions some of the students with whom
I've been closest personally have been
very conservative students and they give
me their feedback just like students who
are closer to my ideological hope you
know situation they give me their
feedback and been a wonderful thing but
students too are part of the reason why
I feel like I've been a very privileged
person Michael in fort Mojave Arizona
please go ahead with your question or
comment for professor Randall Kennedy
yes gentlemen you're privileged here to
have you well both loud
commenting and if they're brought back
to my mind 1965 shortly after Johnson
signed the Civil Rights Act dick the
Watts riot broke
out and in some comments that Johnson's
who made their there I'm paraphrasing is
of course that he felt very dismayed
that that all he had done for the bad
people but their writing and wasit was
well I kind of look at that as a mark I
point in my life work on my own in my
side of my head I I looked at mr.
Johnson said well that you are the still
writes actually are cruel but you didn't
solve the problems that were concerning
the people and watch and then and and
maybe you're like put a little attention
on that but the minor is outright
calling here is IC aka a source of
violence in all communities that is
extreme in black communities and that is
a violation of to constitutional
positions that's say the same thing and
in communities at every minute when they
said that Congress shall pass no bill of
attainder
and that the states will not pass any
bill of attainder now as I understand
bill of attainder it's a law that
targets an identifiable group for
punishment without benefit of trial so
if you if you find somebody with a joint
or hash pipe or some controlled
substance he's in the club that's
something you haven't done anything
alright Michael we're gonna we're going
to leave your comments there and get a
response from Randall Kennedy
well the caller makes two points to
which I want to refer here when you
speak of Lyndon Johnson it's quite a
striking thing that then in 1965 Voting
Rights Act marked in a way the high
point of the civil rights revolution and
as the caller indicated you know within
weeks you had this outbreak in watts
which really did show the way in which
the civil rights revolution for all of
the good that it did I left untouched
important
in Justices in American life in justices
that have not gone away the the the the
Watts riot followed by the Newark riots
followed by the riots in New York Silla
Delphia other places showing the way in
which is particularly inner city America
still suffered grievously under a
combination of racial oppression and
class injustice on the civil rights
revolution really did not transform that
problem and indeed nothing has
transformed that problem we are still
grappling with that problem and the
caller is right to bring our attention
to it with respect to the question of of
black people and the interaction of many
black people with the administration of
criminal justice that was the subject of
my first book race crime and the law
that is still a very sore point because
with respect to virtually every aspect
of the administration of criminal
justice we have a race problem in every
aspect and in every area in America
whether it be the West whether it be the
Northeast whether it be the southeast
everywhere in America we still have a
real problem with respect to racial
discrimination in the administration of
criminal justice and that was the
subject of of my first book it's
probably a subject to which I will
return and it's still a big problem in
American life 1997 race crime in the law
came out and Randall Kennedy wrote maybe
the crack powder distinction and indeed
the entire
war on drugs is mistaken but even if
these policies are misguided being
mistaken is different from being racist
and the difference is one that matters
greatly yes let's talk about the crack
powder distinction because there's been
a lot of talk about that in fact has
been legislation in the last year so the
government passed on a law used to be
that crack was after a certain amount of
crack was if you had a certain amount of
crack you were punished much more
harshly than if you had a certain amount
of powder cocaine there was a certain
there was a so-called hundred to one
ratio that has been diminished somewhat
now I think it's an eighteen to one
ratio there are many people who claim
that the crack powder distinction in
terms of punishment was a racist the
story there as I detail in my book and
as I still believe is quite complicated
it's complicated in the following way
when I was writing my chapter about race
and the war on drugs I did the following
I went to the computer and I went to the
Congressional Record and I typed in
crack cocaine I wanted to see who was
the first person that really talked
about crack cocaine and who are the
people who were behind cracking down on
crack who did I find representative
Charles Rangel and other members of the
Congressional Black Caucus their
position when they when they they went
to Congress and I said listen they
weren't you know in Congress and they
said listen our communities are being
ravaged by this new form of cocaine
called crack cocaine now when things
happen that you know ravaged white
communities there's action people are
concerned about it but when things
happen in black communities all too
often there's indifference
we want to peer students indifference we
want to crack down on crack well the
Congress did crack down on crack and I
think the Congress cracked down on crack
in a way that led to in my view tragic
results but if we're talking about the
crack story we can't forget the role
that black representatives played in it
thinking that they were helping their
community now I think that they were
wrong not I don't think that they were
trying to be wrong I don't think that
they were ill intended their intentions
were good intentions but it miscarried
um I think frankly that the whole war on
drugs has miscarried again not out of
bad intent but you know sometimes people
make mistakes and so my purpose in
writing that sentence that you quoted
was to say that when we go back we need
to recognize that there all sorts of
motivations that people have sometimes
when people do something that we think
has led to bad results it's not because
people intended the bad results it's not
because people were malevolent people
make mistakes and it seems to me that
this is important not just as a matter
of analysis but it's also important as a
political matter because if you're
confronting somebody and you think they
you disagree with what they what they
you know some policy there is a big
difference between saying that policy is
a racist policy and that take that and
that policy is a mistaken policy if you
say that that policy is a racist policy
one consequence may be in part because
racism may get back to an earlier call
has been so stigmatized sometimes some
you know a politician who's been in
favor of a policy you say ah I'm against
that policy it's a racist policy
that politician may be very defensive no
I would never have voted for a racist
policy how dare you call me a racist how
dare you say that I would be in favor of
a racist policy and that person might
say I'm not a racist
I would not be for a racist policy and
they might in fact entrench themselves
they might embrace that policy I love a
human instinct which is a defensive
instinct I'm not a racist I know I'm not
a racist I know I wouldn't be in favor
of a racist policy how dare you say it
I'm really indignant I'm going to double
down on it
that's scenario number one scenario
number two I think that your policy is
mistaken you might have had good
intentions with it in fact let's assume
that you had in good intentions but
we've studied it it's had the following
effects we should change it very often
not always but very often a person
confronting that will have a different
attitude because after all we all make
mistakes we all make mistakes and if you
tell me I've made a mistake Oh
leave isn't that I'm in more of a you
know a more of a mind to listen to you
you know fine I made a mistake I made a
mistake thank you for pointing that out
now let's try to reform it that's what
legislation is about so I think we need
to be very careful with the racist label
and with respect to the crack cocaine
powder cocaine distinction his race part
of it I think race can be part of it so
for instance you might say would
legislators have been more willing to
revisit the issue if the crack powder
distinction had done to white
communities would it it's done to black
communities I think the answer there is
probably so and so do is there a racial
distinction maybe in the way in which
Congress has reacted may
so but still I think we need to be very
careful in labeling actions as racist
when it's possible that they were not
racist in their origins they were merely
mistaken the porter is an Ulta sock
Lahoma this is book TV on c-span - go
ahead - Porter yes a good mind professor
first of all the first question I had
was about a reparations but you answered
it but I went on to add to that you say
that affirmative action was part of
reparations well from the actions did
not have everyone that was affected on
the families that was affected and still
it was affected by slavery but I think
if you put that into a mind turn very
you would also have the American economy
because the Senate might would go back
into the economy buying businesses and
homes and stuff like that
all right my question this is my first
question is do you think the President
Obama although he the black man to
apologize to slavery for the United
States of America and the second
question is me being a bagman and
Muslims what do you think about doing
square con ministers with parents
teachers okay a couple of things first
you're absolutely right in your comment
about affirmative action as a type of
reparations when you make the comment
that it helped affirmative action help
some people but not other people in fact
one of the criticisms of affirmative
action has been that as it works itself
out
usually it helps those who were actually
better off in the black community those
who actually probably bear fewer scars
from slavery and segregation and that's
that's one argument that has been used
as a criticism of affirmative action and
it's it's a good criticism it's true
it's true but sometimes you have to get
you know what redistribution you can and
that's why I'm basically a supporter of
affirmative action even with
it's deficiencies and its inadequacies
but you did put your finger on an
important inadequacy of affirmative
action as it usually plays itself out
now you asked the question about the
Barack Obama and the apology for slavery
it's an interesting question I think
that there should long have been a long
ago have been an apology for slavery one
question that people have with respect
to apologies though is the problem of
the hollow apology that the problem of
the formulaic apology one hears
apologies all the time in life and in
politics and in our culture you want an
apology to be to mean something and I
think that it would be worthwhile
thinking about how we as a society could
craft or whether we should I mean maybe
we should have maybe there should be
some little Commission about this I know
that another representative Conyers has
for a number of years sought to have a
commission to discuss just this issue
one other point on the on the
reparations point there was a wonderful
teacher at Yale Law School number of
years ago named Boris Becker who wrote a
book called the case for black
reparations still a book very worth
reading and one thing that Boris Becker
said he said you know when people talk
about reparations in his view people
talked about slavery too much as soon as
you talk about reparations people
immediately talk about slavery and one
problem with slavery is he said you know
when people talk about slavery they
think about it being so long ago and we
say reparations for slavery peoples as
well they're no more slaves or no more
slave masters that happened long ago so
Victor said no is in spar as he was
concerned it was much more useful to
talk not about slavery but to talk about
segregation now
millions of Americans alive today who
were the direct victims of de jure
segregation in the United States my
mother my dear mother loved Schumer's
washing right now a citizen of South
Carolina could she go to the University
of South Carolina no she could not she
had to go to South Carolina State got a
good education at South Carolina State
she's practicing with the South Carolina
State just like other members of my
family with the South Carolina State
they could not go to the University of
South Carolina when my mother graduated
from South Carolina State University and
wanted to get higher education a
master's degree in education the states
gave her money
to go out of state she went to NYU to
get her master's in education because no
such degree was offered for black people
in South Carolina she was a direct
victim of segregation and she's living
just like there are millions of other
black Americans who are living so in the
discussion of reparations and whether
there should be reparations we should
not think that we should not have our
minds too focused on what happened prior
to 1865 the United States we had a
thermal pigment aa cracy that lasted far
later than that like I said the 1965
Voting Rights Act and it comes closer
formal racial discrimination and victims
of formal racial discrimination are all
around us and I think in talking about
reparations we should remember that
Patrick Miami good afternoon and
professor Kennedy thank you for taking
my call I was struck by your concept of
the sellout it is a word that's been
livid against myself before I'm a
Vanderbilt and Yale graduate with a very
nice position in the company
here in the United States and I think
it's there and that and that concept of
sellout where there's a lot of grounds
to be covered still in the black
community I'm wondering what your
thoughts are on how we begin to shift
the paradigm so that the achievements
that we associate with selling out are
not viewed with suspicion or in a
pejorative way by the black community at
large but as a way to really sort of
ignite the concept of the race man that
you talk about so eloquently thank you
it's a complicated thing and again we
have to remember that black America is
tremendously complex or all sorts of
positions we just finished with you know
Black History Month and all through
Black History Month this month and
historically a lot of pride is expressed
about black American firsts and black
Americans who had succeeded in all
spheres you know business law inventing
things medicine and so people in the
audience should not you know think that
you know all black Americans look
askance at black Americans who have
succeeded there is a very strong
tradition in in black America of
applauding black Americans who have gone
out in society and proven their mettle
at the same time there is this suspicion
that is still there and know even in
places even in places of privilege and
in in in sellout the very end of the
book I talk about why I wrote it in one
reason I wrote it is because at my law
school Harvard Law School clearly a
place of tremendous privilege there's
still a certain anxiety that bubbles up
so you have students who come to me at
office hours we'll be talking about
careers and there will be a certain sort
of anxiety Express or almost a sort of
a feeling of guilt Express with people
saying things went like well I really
don't know if I want to pursue this sort
of career because if I do this won't
idea be a mere assimilationist won't I
be selling out won't I be you know
distance this thing saying myself rail
from my people and you know my response
is listen I we live in a huge society
there are people of talent needed all
over the place
do your thing if you want to be a great
tax attorney be a great tax attorney
you're not going to be selling out if
you want to be a mergers and
acquisitions attorney if you want to be
a corporate attorney do it do your thing
that's what I tell students do just like
just like Thurgood Marshall did his
thing I work for Thurgood Marshall is
one of the great experiences of my life
he's always been a hero to me but
sometimes I get the feeling that people
think that a person like Thurgood
Marshall they speak is if he was you
know a monitor that he was um being a
civil rights attorney and that it was
all a matter of drudgery for him it
wasn't a matter of drudgery for him he
was doing what he wanted to do he loved
doing what he wanted to do that's one of
the reasons he was so excellent at doing
what he did um and I would say that if
you want to be a whatever kind of lawyer
you want to be a defense lawyer you want
to be a prosecutor knock yourself out
grab that passion and do it and don't be
worried about this Landis notion of you
know am i am i doing enough to help my
community to tell you the truth if I
would I would very much subordinate that
way of thinking if you are a good person
acting
and you know within the law and uh it's
advancing yourself you especially if
you're a black American if you're doing
those things you'll probably be
inspiring others and that is a good
thing don't don't worry frankly about
the sellout concern
do your thing that would be my month out
that's my advice this is in depth on
book TV on c-span 2 this month professor
and author Randall Kennedy is our guest
every time we have an author on we
always ask for some of their influences
and favorite books and what they're
reading and we're going to show that to
you now along with a little bit of video
from Professor Kennedy talking about
interracial intimacy's and we will
continue taking your calls after this
[Music]
about interracial relationships there a
variety of reasons one is I think that
interracial intimacy these sorts of
relationships with which I'm most
concerned friendship sexual
relationships marital relationships
familial relationships are understudied
I teach at a law school teach at Harvard
Law School I teach a course on race
relations law in such a course note
there's no good people expect for you
spend a long time of talking about the
law the regulation of race at the
workplace the regulation of raise with
respect to housing markets the
regulation of race with respect to
education spend a lot of time on that
people don't think about spending a lot
of time on the regulation of race with
respect to marital intimacy sexual
intimacy though if you think about it if
you think about how people get jobs if
you think about how people conceive of
themselves if you think about how people
learn learn about the world these sorts
of relationships are incredibly
important friendship as an institution
bading as an institution is incredibly
important and one thing that drew me to
this subject was the extent to which
people actually did not talk about it
and actually thought of these sorts of
relationships as being rather trivial
and we are back live with Professor
Randall Kennedy and interracial
intimacy's professor you write that you
wanted that book to provoke readers to
rethink their casual reliance on racial
distinction in their private affairs yes
I mean so for instance in friendships in
dating in marriage I think that for many
people there's sort of
ritual just by habit you go to some
place and you're looking around you know
who you're going to talk with we race
code you know and we go to people who
our society has told us we should go to
and I'm saying that's being self
conscious and recognize that um frankly
we need to undo the habits that we have
inherited and we need to self
consciously um seek out other sorts of
people there's nothing wrong with that
people are people let's let's go outside
of our expectations let's go outside of
the normal bounds
let's open ourselves up to people that
we would not have normally opened
ourselves up to that's what I was
encouraging in an interracial intimacy
and we are talking with Harvard Law
Professor Randall Kennedy who is also
the author of five books these are his
five books his first book that came out
in 1997 was race crime and the law
followed by the N word book which came
out in 2002 2003 was interracial
intimacy's but that we were just
discussing fell out came out in 2008 and
finally the persistence of the color
line is his most recent book it came out
last year and Professor Kennedy
indicated that he is working on a sixth
book which is do when when do you see
that being published it'll be published
uh early next year it will be published
in the spring of 2013 and it'll be a
book about affirmative action does it
have a title you know it does not have a
working title it's just it's going to be
about the law and politics of
affirmative action and of course one of
the reasons why my publisher wanted me
to expedite the book is because the
Supreme Court just decided that it would
review an affirmative action case
involving the univer
if Texas law school so my publisher is
assuming that next spring that's going
to be a issue very much on the front
pages and they want to have my book out
around that time by the way when I
mentioned my publisher you know I said
earlier in our conversation that I feel
so fortunate in my associations and one
aspect of that has to do with the people
who actually produce my books you know
in legal academia most legal academics
sort of make their mark through writing
review of writing articles for law
reviews and I wrote for a number of
years Law Review articles and thoroughly
enjoyed doing that and one of my Law
Review articles was excerpted in the
wall street journal it was an article
about the administration of criminal
justice and a fellow read that article
by the name of Errol McDonald he's a an
editor at Pantheon books he calls me off
and he says this was an interesting
article you should make it into a book
and I said you know I've been thinking
about writing a book and fine so then we
talked for a few minutes the next day I
had a contract and I've been with them
ever since and he got me into writing
books
he's been my editor ever since Pantheon
has been my publisher and I must say I
feel tremendous sense of gratitude and
gratification through my association
with Errol McDonald and michiko Clarke
and Lt Carper and the people at Pantheon
books who helped me put out these
cultural productions we're going to put
the numbers up on the screen in case
you'd like to participate in our
conversation with professor Randall
Kennedy and you can also contact us
electronically book TV at c-span org is
our email address or Twitter twitter.com
slash book TV if you would like to leave
a comment there as well in the
persistence of the color-line racial
politics in the obama presidency in
writing about the 2008 election you talk
about the Clintons and the race card but
you reference an article you wrote for
the Atlantic in 2001 called the triumph
of robust tokenism what is that about
the Atlantic magazine wanted an article
wanted as a bunch of people to write
articles about the legacy of Bill
Clinton's presidency and they wanted me
to talk about Bill Clinton and
african-americans and basically what I
said was that Bill Clinton got an
extraordinary reception from African
Americans a lot of applause from African
Americans I thought that African
Americans frankly gave him too much
applause had credited him excessively I
thought that what a much of what he had
done fell under the rubric of tokenism
but and here's what the title came in I
said you know it was robust tokenism
and I don't see our tokenism I mean
tokenism can be important oftentimes
tokenism is used as a put-down a merely
symbolic but I think symbolism is you
know can be very important and I thought
that Bill Clinton had done certain
things which furthered the overall
project of inclusion the inclusion of
black Americans at the highest levels of
American government he had furthered
that and I wanted to give him you know
his uh leo due credit for that not too
much credit but due credit and that's
what that article is about next call for
Professor Kennedy comes from Haley in
Lakewood Washington go ahead Haley Haley
with us you hearing anything professor
no okay we're going to have to move on
and we're going to go to Milton in
Philadelphia hi Milton
hey good one Leslie Oh can you hear me
okay
you know what I have problems with black
conservatism is this I understand that
you have issues with President Obama and
his policies right but this criticism of
him about the fact that he had to
produce his birth certificate in these
comments that he's not one of us oh he
was Bay Rays by his father from Kenya
he's a socialist and all these attacks
against them you cannot help us see that
is racially motivated and here you have
representatives for Florida like West
and all of these other black
conservatives where are they out there
denouncing this criticism of President
Obama okay first of all I agree with the
caller that some not all not all by any
means but some of the criticism of
President Obama as far as I'm concerned
is certainly fueled by racial animus
racial resentment some of it is just
out-and-out some of it is out and out
racist and you know just said so on its
face some of it is a little bit more
subtle a sort of sublimated racism and
so I agree with the call or I agree with
the caller that there are there has been
an insufficient criticism of the racist
attacks on President Obama that had come
from conservatives now there are two
other aspects of the the callers remarks
that I'd like to note one has to do with
the whole issue of President Obama and
it was he born in in the United States
clearly he was born in the United States
one point that I don't think has been
paid enough attention to however is the
the wisdom of that part of the United
States Constitution that says that the
president United States must be born in
the United States I think at that part
of the United States Constitution ought
to be um we
ought to be rescinded we ought to have a
constitutional amendment that removes
that part of our Constitution there are
at least 700 people who have won the
Congressional Medal of Honor who are
naturalized citizens of the United
States there are thousands of people who
are buried in Arlington National
Cemetery who paid the ultimate price on
behalf of the United States who are
naturalized citizens of the United
States there are millions of people in
the United States who were born in some
other country why shouldn't they be
eligible to be President of the United
States we've had people we had
secretaries of state who were born
abroad we've had Supreme Court justices
who were born abroad I think that
frankly it should be no bar to be born
abroad the president United States
Barack Obama was not born abroad and
many of those who have raised that as an
objection to him I think are indulging
in a sort of code language they don't
want to be viewed as racist so they come
up with some other reason to oppose the
president I think that's going on just
like the caller indicated and I think
that that ought to be criticized but I
didn't want to put in there that the
whole idea that you had to be a
natural-born citizen of the United
States to be President it seems to me
that that's an antiquated and mistaken
notion now one do you like Sanford
Levinson I did I'm a big fan of a
professor Samford Levin's this email I
have not read any of your books but now
I want to my question our blacks who
hold deeply conservative views like
Clarence Thomas Thomas ole Herman Cain
or JC Watts among the sellouts in your
book and actually you talked about the
politics and the GOP in the persistence
of the color line yes but expensive
um they can be I don't they don't
necessarily have to be at all the fact
of the matter is that black America is
ideologically varied just like
Latino America just like white America
just like Asian American Asian American
just like Asian Americans you know there
are black people who are quite
conservative in various way there are
black libertarians there are black uh
religious fundamentalists of various
sorts do I claim that any of these
people are necessarily sellouts no not
at all and I again am loath to use the
term sellout in my view you have to I
want to define it very very very
narrowly and so I think for instance in
American life rankly there are
relatively few sellouts period I want to
have a very narrow definition because
that term that idea the notion of
traitorous Ness it's a it's it's a
complicated notion it's a tricky notion
it's a notion that does it's quite
destructive instead of calling somebody
a sellout and by the way it also needs
to be remarked that sometimes sometimes
people who are sellouts are heroes think
about for instance um think about a
white person who grew up are with Ku
Klux Klansmen for neighbors who turned
against the Klan and their neighbors
said uh you're sellout well yeah they
were sellout they weren't traitors god
bless them so I mean the fact that
you're you know that the fact that you
are a traitor is not even in itself bad
at all depends on a traitor against what
what about what about Germans who turn
to get Hitler were they trade or the
other they were traitors god bless them
so I the true you know saw it's a
complicated one it's not even
necessarily a bad thing
depends on what your selling out and you
know can one be a black conservative
and not B FL yes one can be a black
conservative not via sellout I'm not
conservative I think it would be better
to challenge people based on their views
if you disagree with somebody you know
you think this I think it's wrong for
this this and this reason let's talk
about the issues not turn and you know
not turn the discussion into what is
often a just naked Lee ad hominem
discussion about who's a traitor and who
is that it often doesn't take in where
we should want to go and in sellout
Randall Kennedy writes the use of black
spies to maintain surveillance of black
activists was ongoing systematic and
extensive in 1967 the FBI launched a
ghetto informant program aimed at
enabling officials to monitor the tenor
of public opinion in black communities
by the summer of 68 the FBI had hired
some 3248 individuals to develop its
ghetto listening posts under the
direction of the FBI black spies and
agent provocateurs penetrated virtually
all of the significant black activist
organizations the consequences for the
Panthers were catastrophic
they became consumed with weeding out
traitors falling prey to a collective
paranoia that led to constant purging
Xand at least one murder of a member
charged with disloyalty yes yes again
every group has had to deal with this
problem again to give back to the
callers and can't have there been people
who've quite literally been paid to
infiltrate black organizations at the
behest of white supremacist
organizations the answer is yes it
happened in Mississippi the Mississippi
sovereignty Commission paid black
informants to you know tell on their
their neighbors and that is a part
black American history that has not
gotten frankly enough attention it's an
interesting part a very disturbing part
but a part of history that ought not be
surprising again every group has had to
grapple with this the episode that you
mentioned especially with respect to the
Black Panther Party does show the way in
which we when you start trying to find
out who's a traitor sometimes the very
effort to do that is worse than just
having a traitor amongst your midst
because it does lead to you know
paranoia and makes groups very often uh
vulnerable to outside manipulation which
is one of the things unfortunately that
befell the Black Panther Party franny
lead tweets in my understanding of
sellout is someone that made it with
help from others the group but tends to
forget about them doesn't give back well
that's that's the definition that some
people have I had many people use it
like that I would be a little bit more
demanding given the harshness of the
term and the consequences that flow from
being labeled a sellout but it's true
that you know some people just view -
you know people who've sort of made it
up the ladder
with the help of other people and then
show selfishness there after Algiers
lady tweets into you professor in the
structure of black classes have you ever
ventured in the average black life by
living within eg the book black like I'm
sorry have you ever ventured into the
average black life by living within is
what it says for example or for example
black like me well you know this is an
instance in which I didn't have to do
the with the guy and black like me did
I guess I could write a book called
black like me but I didn't mean the
journalists in black like me had to do a
whole bunch of things to make himself
dark so that he would be taken as a
black person I don't have to do do that
I can go to practically every aspect in
the United States and given the way I
look people will assume that I'm black
and you know and I've traveled pretty
widely I've indicated in the past that
I've lived a very privileged life as I
have one of the aspects of that
privilege is that I have I have had the
benefit of seeing a wide range of black
American life so my parents were not
wealthy people at all we were you know
just I'd say you know working-class
folks live in a working-class community
in Washington DC spent a lot of time
growing up in the deep south with with
my aunts with my grandmother began Big
Mama in South Carolina so I've seen a
pretty wide swath of a black American
life and that I think his it stood me in
good stead as I've written these various
books about race relations in America a
tear Azul Murphy emails into you
professor please comment on Michelle
Alexander's thesis in the new Jim Crow
that today's system of mass
incarceration is a reinvention of the
undercast
of slavery and Jim Crow yeah well I
think that Professor Alexander's book
has been useful to the in in publicizing
and in highlighting the problem and the
injustice of mass incarceration and
hyper incarceration and hyper punitive
'no sin america the united states
imprisons a larger percentage of its
population by far by far than any other
advanced society in the world and it
does this in my view needlessly i think
that we are creating needless misery in
the way in which we are just wasting
lives by putting people in prison who
ought not be in prison and so i'm glad
if she's pretty shown a light on that
and I think her title the new Jim Crow
has focused people's attention on that
on the other hand do I have some
criticisms with the title I do because
um you know the the the system of Jim
Crow segregation was a very specific
system it was a function of explicit
white supremacy what we have now in
America is more complex and I and I
think that we need to start working on
creating new vocabularies I mean the new
Jim Crow the United States who is the
top official overseeing the United
States prison system who is the ultimate
boss of the United States prison system
the boss of the United Sates prison
system is the Attorney General of the
United States Eric Holder is a black
American well that doesn't still
with the new Jim Crow analogy I mean in
the Jim Crow system you didn't have
black attorneys general in Jim Crow you
didn't have a black chief executive of
the United States in the you know Jim
Crow you didn't have black officials in
the cities I mean how many black
officials do you have with you know
Chiefs of Police ah black judges the
fact of the matter is that you do have
black officials strategically placed who
are also implicated in this terrible
system that we have and so I mean the
Jim Crow analogy does capture attention
but I also think that it obscures
important new features of our society so
I want us to develop some new words new
a new vocabulary to deal with issues
that are truly new in American life
Daniel in Woodridge New Jersey thanks
for holding you're on with author and
professor Randall Kennedy on book TV
hello professor Kennedy it's such a
privilege to talk to you I have learned
so much from your book particularly the
race crime and law and the other book so
I consider you in my tradition a guru so
it's such a great privilege to be able
to talk to you I'm also an adjunct
professor at John Jay College of
Criminal Justice and the question I want
to ask you was about the criminal
justice system and it seems to me and
I'm in the process of writing a new book
called the last plantation the criminal
does the last plantation the last
plantation the criminal justice system
and blacks in the United States it seems
to me that you also
you also had a question discussion a
little bit earlier about the injustice
of crack and cocaine statute for me it
seems that the more fundamental question
is about really the racial implications
of the war on drugs the war on drugs if
you look at historically and obviously a
very very brief here and I because I
want to listen to your answer it has
been compared historically to the Black
Codes immediately after the emancipation
here see first of all thank you very
much for your compliments and I have a
tremendous respect for your institution
and the person who who heads it or your
president Jeremy Travis I think that do
we have a race problem in the
administration of criminal justice at
every level answer yes we do so I'm not
saying that we've but there's not racial
discrimination in the administration of
criminal justice there is and that's an
important feature of it that we need to
continue to attack still there have been
important changes so you mentioned the
war on drugs I mean there are very
important sectors of black America that
are you know invested in the war on
drugs some of the people who are the
most hawkish of our elected politicians
on the war on drugs are black
politicians so it's not simply just a
white black thing I think that if for
instance on the war on drugs I don't
think the best way of attacking the war
on drugs is frankly to racialize the
issue I think what we need to do is ask
what do we think about the war on drugs
on its merits there are lots of white
people that are in prison I think
wrongly because of the war on drugs
I think that the war on drugs is
misleading
I think it's mistaken I think it is cool
in certain respects I think that it is
fueled a tremendous violation of civil
liberties in America there are lots of
reasons outside of the racial context
there are lots of reasons to be against
the war on drugs I think that there
needs to be more attention frankly
placed on those I don't want to forget
about the race issue it's there but
sometimes it takes up actually too much
attention and I think that people
haven't heard enough sometimes about
some of the other reasons non-racial
reasons why the war on drugs in my view
has been a real disaster I would urge
you to in thinking about your you know
your upcoming book you know the new
plantation there are some people you
know professor Alexander there are
others who try to analogize older racial
regimes to the present system again for
rhetorical purposes that has certain
benefits but I think it often obscures
more than it illuminate professor
Kennedy Christopher tweets into you
since you are now a proponent of
affirmative action how do you predict
that the Supreme Court will evaluate
affirmative action when it hears Fisher
this fall yeah I think in the case
Fisher versus Texas which the Supreme
Court said a few weeks ago it's good to
side in the next term I think it's
highly likely that the Supreme Court
will limit racial affirmative
affirmative action more it is already
limited it it's allowed it it's allowed
at some breathing room but over the past
10 years 15 years it's the courts
including the Supreme Court of the
United States is increasingly limited
the scope of racial affirmative action I
think in this come
in case the Fisher case the Supreme
Court will limit it more I don't think
that the Supreme Court will say that
race cannot under any circumstances be
taken into account in selecting students
I think it will give it some breathing
room but less breathing room I think by
the way that will be an unfortunate step
that the Supreme Court will take but I
suspect that that is the step that is
forthcoming from the court this is an
email from Keith Williams in Homewood
Alabama professor Kennedy you admitted
your feelings of black racial solidarity
have grown over the years
what is your opinion on similar feelings
growing in the American white community
as it transitions in numbers from
majority to plurality and even minority
status over the next several decades
it's a good question um and here's what
I'd say or I recall earlier amending my
comment about racial solidarity I'm I
guess I'm only for racial solidarity if
it is on behalf of some other wider uh
goal so I'm not for black solidarity
merely for the purpose of black
solidarity I'm for black solidarity in
circumstances in a political struggle
where black solidarity is useful to
change things to have a more just
society I'm not for black solidarity
just for black solidarity sake I'm not
for black people you know just because
I'm black and I just you know want black
people to do well I want a more decent
just society and so if people are
banding together in a particularly
just society for everyone okay that's
all right with me but if people are
gathering together narcissistically or
try ballistically you know we're just
gathering together to gather together
for ourselves and ourselves only now I'm
against that whether it's white people
whether it's black people whether it's
anybody I when you think about the
history of race relations in the u.s.
where does the case of Henry Lewis gates
your Harvard colleague where does that
fit and how significant is that when you
write about in the persistence of the
color so when you say the case of Henry
Louis Gates you're talking about that
when he was arrested in his own home yes
is a complicated story
first of all Henry Louis Gates Jr Henry
Louis Gates Jr is a university professor
they're not very many of them it's sort
of the highest level of professor at
Harvard University he's certainly one of
the most well known professors in the
United States probably the world is a
very privileged character a very
impressive person and he had you know
one of one of the leading most
influential intellectuals in American
life he has at his disposal in America
what the great wev de bois could only
have imagined to have had so when you
say Henry Louis Gates Jr you know Henry
Louis Gates Jr the trajectory of his
life is an illustration of how American
life has opened up tremendously over you
know the past hundred years at the same
time here you have this guy he's a
university professor he takes a trip to
China he's on he comes home he finds
that his door won't open so he and the
man who get who drove him home
a cabdriver livery driver and jiggle
with the door a neighbor says calls it
the police and says I don't know for
sure whether there's a break-in going on
but they're these two guys who look like
they're you know you know trying to
[ __ ] with the door to get in I don't
know what's going on police officer goes
over by this time Henry Louis Gates is
in his house the police officer comes in
asked him for identification
brother professor gates is not too happy
about that but ultimately shows an
identification telling them he lives in
the house it's his house they had words
the officers essentially lures them
outside professor gates is screaming at
the office of the officer arrests them
for disorderly conduct now in my view of
the officer was wrong in arresting
professor gates even if it was the case
that professor gates was uh not being
deferential to the officer even if it
was the case that professor gates was
hollering at the officer police officers
carry around weapons they should be very
well trained they should have discipline
they should have enough training such
that they don't get unhinged simply
because somebody is giving them a lip so
you know I don't think that somebody
should be arrested for giving a police
officer lip that's essentially what
Henry Louis Gates was arrested for I
think that's a bad thing but it doesn't
end there the issue we were talking
about the issue because there's a
presidential press conference and
somebody asked the President of the
United States what do you think about
this police officer arresting Henry
Louis Gates Jr well here we have a
situation where this very famous
professor is asked somebody asked about
the arrest of this very famous professor
and who does he ask yes the first black
president of the United States well
again this too is an illustration of our
remarkable moment
the president is the black president of
the United States he gives an answer
that a lot of people don't like he says
well I don't know you know I'm not
saying that this was racist in any way
I'm just saying it seems me it was a
stupid thing that the police officer did
now some people interestingly enough
made it seem as though Barack Obama had
accused the police officer of acting in
a racist way he did not all he said was
the police officer acted stupidly I
agree with President Obama on that but
the president backed back off of that
yeah this sort of the famous beer summit
I think here we have an interesting
clash of things on the one hand we have
many black men who are not as privileged
as Henry Louis Gates they didn't get out
of jail immediately there are many black
men who would probably have languished
in jail for a good long while not having
done anything worse than Henry Louis
Gates Jr he was protected by his
privilege so again we still have a race
problem in American life but Wow have
things changed Wow have things changed
since the time that my parents left
South Carolina fleeing Jim Crow
segregation with their young kids things
have changed quite dramatically and you
know we should be happy however you feel
about Barack Obama Williams reform or
again them we as Americans should feel
happy that there has been substantial
progress on the racial front in these
United States Katrina in Detroit thanks
for holding you're on with Randall
Kennedy thank you so much mr. Kennedy
I've never heard of you before but he
promised to go out and read as much as
your materials I can't I want to respond
to the veteran the a rat veteran saying
that african-americans are racist
I would just like to ask you a question
as where do we draw that line
african-americans have never in all of
our history had any paper hate group
that just went out and targeted
different groups and made cartoons about
them what I believe what he's trying
what he's misinterpreting is that when
they come into firing every father has
come into black communities we've always
accepted him wait until their
establishment and then once we notice
that the products are not as good
they're smelling their weeks owned they
don't hire anybody from the community
then once we voice those opinions to
them or those concerns to them all of a
sudden we are labeled as racist and I
want you to say is that is is that
attitude of washing your concerns about
businesses in the community being a
racist got the point Katrina say okay
now here's website of course if there is
a business in a community and you think
that the person is selling bad goods or
overcharging or refusing to hire people
because of their race of course those
concerns should be voiced and I have no
objection whatsoever to raising such
concerns though that that's perfectly
fine but I don't think actually that
that's what the previous caller was
saying I think what the previous caller
was saying that I think what he was
saying was that he had seen or
experienced instances in which black
Americans had objected to the fae a
business not because the business was
doing anything bad but solely because of
the background of the business person
whether the business person was a person
from
you know from the Middle East or a
person from you know from careered
or something else and the person was
saying just isn't a bad thing when black
people object to people or mistreat
people solely on solely on the basis or
at all on the basis of their background
and I was simply saying yeah that's a
bad thing at black people say that you
know I'm against this business because
this business person comes from you know
I don't know Iraq or Saudi Arabia or
whatever that's the reason why I'm
against this business then I think
that's a bad thing and I don't think
that we should be at all
um apologetic about eschewing
repudiating that sort of thing have I
seen you know black people act in a
racist way yeah sure I've seen black
people act in a racist way I've seen
black pee I have seen black Americans
speak disparagingly about black Africans
I've seen black Americans speak
disparagingly about black people from
the Caribbean I mean you know these
things happen
within black America and it seems to me
that we often I said when I say we I'm
thought we black Americans ought to be
very forthright in saying we're not
going to stand for that and by the way
we ought not to stand for black
Americans acting in a racist way toward
white Americans and have I seen that yes
I've seen that too we ought not stand
for black Americans acting in a way that
is unjustifiable towards other people
based on you know sexual orientation
religion or race or any characteristic
that is an unjustifiable basis for you
know being against people this tweet
from Deborah dickerson Dickerson from
your former RA is that research research
assistant yes what do you think of the
black intelligentsia
rejection of the Occupy movement while
occupy the hood embraces it well it's
good to hear from from Deborah Dickerson
absolutely former research assistant and
and student but thank you very much for
saying that tweets good to hear from you
um I want to argue with the premise of
your question I do not think that the
black intelligentsia in a wholesale
fashion has rejected the Occupy movement
there have been some features of the
black intelligentsia that unfortunately
have have you know sort of poo-pooed the
Occupy movement complaining that you
know too many white people I've heard
that I think that's a very unfortunate
response but I don't think that it's
fair to say that that's the black
intelligencia that's part of the black
inteligencia I think that there there
are wider parts of the black
inteligencia that have been frankly very
supportive of the Occupy movement and
its concerns and its aims and its goals
about 30 minutes left in this month in
depth with professor and author Randall
Kennedy of the Harvard School of Law
five books under his belt one more
coming in January 2013 here the five
that Professor Kennedy has already
written rice race crime and the law came
out in 1997 the n-word the strange
career of a troublesome word in 2002
which was a best-seller interracial
intimacy's came out in 2003 and
professor Kennedy has indicated that
that of his five books is his personal
favorite sellout came out in 2008 and
his most recent the persistence of the
color line in 2011 and in the
persistence of the color color line
professor you write Obama is determined
to avoid venturing beyond what he
perceives as the comfort zone of a
majority of voters
no topic is his caution more evident
than race relations because that topic
remains volatile and because his
blackness makes him particularly
vulnerable to demagoguery Obama avoids
confronting the American race question
thus underscoring its central but
repressed and paradoxical presence in
the political culture of the United
States yes so here we have the first
black American president he gave a
speech during his campaign is most by
far his most celebrated speech a more
perfect union in Philadelphia in which
the the immediate impetus behind the
speech was to quell the controversy
about his relationship with his pastor
Jeremiah Wright but he went on further
to talk about race relations and in his
speech he said you know race relations a
very important subject and we're going
to have to you know talk about it beyond
you know just one speech well during the
rest of the campaign you didn't hear any
more speeches and on race and certainly
as president of the United States you
have not heard you had not heard one
single speech devoted to you know racial
issues in American life now I say that
as a descriptive statement I'm not
putting him down for that some people do
but I don't
he's an electoral politician who has to
play by the the the imperatives of
electoral politics the central
imperative of electoral politics is to
get enough votes to win he is not going
to do anything that is going to turn off
voters who he needs and you know talking
about race is not going to be helpful to
him and so he's a very good politician
and so he's not going to talk about race
and he hasn't we were just talking about
the the issue of the arrest in my view
the very bogus arrest of Henry Louis
Gates Jr he said very you know that's he
thought it was a stupid arrest there was
a
big reaction to that within two days the
President had backtracked he said he
wished that he hadn't poured girls
fuel on the fire he hadn't be invited
the officer to come to the White House
President Gaetz to come to Professor
gates to come to the White House
that was an into it you did not see the
president talk about the you know the
larger racial questions around the
administration of criminal justice in
American life you're not going to see it
and one reason you're not going to see
it is because the race question an
important question in American life is
not a good issue for this president and
is especially not it's especially not a
good issue because he's black there
would be more room frankly for a white
president with his ideological
background to talk about race than him
uh he's black if he people are going to
be viewing everything he says with hyper
sensitivity and so he's not going to
talk about it and like I say and like I
said my book that he doesn't talk about
it he's obviously concerned about it
he's obviously a person who's thought
much about it take a look at his memoir
take a look at what he taught when he
was a when he didn't he taught at the
University of Chicago Law School he's
even a thoughtful person a well-read
person a learned person I'm sure that
this is an issue that matters to him a
lot but you know the electoral
imperatives tell him stay away from this
issue and as a discipline politician and
as a politician who wants to succeed he
is going to listen to those imperatives
next call for Professor Kennedy comes
from Betty in Houston go ahead Betty Oh
Debbie Debbie sorry about that
yeah it's intended to taking my call I
would like to object--
to President Obama
being constantly referred to as black
and the first black president
his mother was white he is a mixed-race
he'd always a itself being post-racial
and of mixed-race he's done a wonderful
job of trying to include and be
inclusive and bringing all people into
the process I think he doesn't want to
be pigeonholed as the you know the first
flag he's obviously the first mixed-race
president we've had okay we'll leave it
there and you write about that and I do
talk about color I do talk about that I
think that it was a very important thing
the way in which Barack Obama turned
himself Barack Obama as an adult has
referred to himself consistently and
unequivocally as black or
african-american there was a for
instance the latest census there was
talk they one of the no well you know
which box did you check he could have
caught himself all sorts of things there
are hundreds of thousands of Americans
who have a parent who's white and a
parent who's black who called themselves
you know multiracial or mixed-race or
something else he could have done that
he did not he referred to himself as
black that's why I call him black uh and
I think that as a political matter that
that turned out to be a quite important
decision on his on his part so you know
you can say that he's mixed-race yeah I
suppose although frankly you could say
that we're all mixed-race a very large
part of the American there's been a lot
of mixing and matching an American life
and then if you you know globalize that
there's been even more mixing and
matching you know the question of what
we decide to call ourselves is you know
of a political decision a political
choice I don't think frankly that we
have to be any
particular thing we don't have to call
ourselves any racial name that is
something that we do as a political
matter and this person Barack Obama has
decided to call himself black and that's
why I call him black professor Kennedy
you say that you are currently reading a
book called defending white democracy by
Jason Morgan Ward what does that book
about on that is a book about
segregationist fought in the 1940s and
1950s in a sense before the outbreak of
the sort of the full eruption of the
civil rights revolution what Professor
war talks about is you know what what
were what were white supremacist saying
in the 40s and 50s
how were they seeking to hold back what
became the civil rights revolution and
it's a very fine book and I've derived a
lot of knowledge a lot of information
and knowledge from from from reading it
and another book you are currently
reading a laundry Nelson body and soul
the Black Panther Party in the fight
against medical discrimination yes well
Alondra Nelson who is a very
distinguished professor at Columbia
University has written a new book about
the Black Panther Party one of the
things that I like so much about this
book is that it presents the Black
Panther Party in a light that's unusual
and you know when you say Black Panther
Party people immediately think of raised
fists I think of leather coats they
think of people brandishing guns they
think of fiery rhetoric but they don't
think of that's it that that's sort of
exhaust the men you know the the
knowledge base of most people when you
when they think when you think when they
do folk the idea of the Black Panther
Party well this book talks about the way
in which the Black Panther Party sought
to assist black Americans
with medical care I talks about the way
in which the Black Panther Party created
clinics the way which the Black Panther
Party criticized what they viewed as
inadequate provision of medical care
the way in which the Black Panther Party
actually nudged this is the overall
society to democratize the provision of
health care and so what Professor Nelson
does is shine a light a very intelligent
a very bright a very vivid light on an
aspect of the Black Panther Party that
nobody else had paid much attention to
so that book is certainly one of my
favorites and again I learned a lot from
from that book John in Sacramento good
afternoon to you good day gentlemen
my question is a real quick one uh you
have the Chinese community in which in
every city in America you can find a
Chinatown the Chinese community takes
care to Chinese people we have doctors
lawyers dentists anything you need in a
Chinese community the dollar circles in
their community the Jewish community of
the same way Jewish community dominates
in Hollywood and in banking and they
assist others you to the point where
they created a whole other nation and
you have the Irish community and which
you know the police fire department
nursing has a large number of Irish
people John I got - we got your point
what's your question well my question is
should not the black privilege did we
help the black poor and under poor as
other communities by helping the people
in their community thank you okay I
think it's a wonderful question I'd say
two things about it one ah yes because I
think that people who are privileged
with education privileged with resources
should help those who have less just as
a general matter and I'd say the same
thing within black community
and frankly I think that that has been
done has it been done enough no it
hasn't been done enough and it's never
done enough in various community listen
in you know the Boston area we you know
of locust of emigration from Ireland
you have class relations within the
Irish community those who did you know
we're successful did better moved away
from the old neighborhoods just like
it's just like you know you have class
stratification within the Irish
community just like you have class
stratification within black communities
just like there there are people in the
Irish community who complain about the
more privileged Irish having moved away
and not paying enough attention not sort
of giving back enough just like you have
in the black community I think these
various communities same thing could be
said about Chinese community
japanese-american community these
various communities act in very similar
ways people talk about Jews you know you
go back to the early 20th century poor
Jews complain bitterly about the well
law of German Jews who look down their
noses at them so I don't think that
black Americans have acted and you know
any worse than any other community and
indeed I would say that in certain ways
there has been considerably more
solidarity within black communities in
part because of the force of just an
overall white supremacy that forced
black Americans to show more racial
solidarity than was the case and other
sort of ethnic communities mud stick
tweets into you professor will there
ever be a time when the affirmative
action lottery tickets can be given to
poor instead of minority it's a great
question it will certainly feature as an
important part of my book because there
are people who were saying listen I
No why should a black middle class or
affluent people get a push when they're
poor white people who don't now to tell
you the truth if I were king and could
do whatever I wanted to do I would be in
I would turn in I would be happy to turn
in racial affirmative action for a
full-throated comprehensive um a
redistribution of opportunity and wealth
and society that paid no attention to
racial lines I would be absolutely
willing to make that trade but guess
what that's not going to happen in
America it leaves not for the
foreseeable future so I'm in the
position of either accepting racial
affirmative action for all of its limits
or no redistribution at all and
therefore I'll take a racial affirmative
action with all of its limits one of the
things that people ought to think about
when they you know hear people criticize
racial affirmative action and these in
some of the critics say what we should
have is you know class not race we need
to ask some questions so you're saying
class not race okay now how much money
how many how much in terms of resources
are you going to be willing to dedicate
to class because if we have to be very
careful there are a lot more there are a
lot more poor white people than poor
people of color in the United States and
if we're not willing to a lot enough
running for all poor people you can
easily have a situation in which poor
right that people get the huge share of
the benefit and poor black people are
left out almost entirely that's one
thing we need to be concerned about we
also need to be
turned about the following I know people
who say you know a class not race they
say that on Monday but then if racial
affirmative action was gotten rid of on
Tuesday where would these people be on
Wednesday they said on Monday that they
were in favor of class not race would
they be saying that on Wednesday when it
was time to for instance raise taxes no
one Wednesday that might very well say
well you know in principle in favor of
class not race but I certainly don't
want to raise taxes for that and having
gotten rid of racial affirmative action
they would be fully willing to lead a
fit that the status quo alone with
racial affirmative action gone that's
one of the things that I'm very
concerned about just about ten minutes
left in this month's in-depth our guest
is Randall Kennedy Loren in an Atlanta
go ahead with your question or comment
thank you and thank you for a
fascinating conversation I would like to
add a different viewpoint to it then get
your learned opinion I believe that the
medical community should recognize
racism is a form of mental illness
because racism greatly diminishes a
person's mental and reasoning capacity
and some of these side effects of racism
such as debilitating ignorance low
self-esteem a false sense of superiority
and erosion of the heart of the mind and
a spiritual hip hopera thing that I've
logic these things debilitating they
need psychiatric treatment so I think we
got the point
thanks Laurie I think it's an
interesting idea well we're thinking
about more than I have thought about it
one caution that immediately comes to
mind is if you call something you know
am ill with mental illness you
immediately take away from the persons
who suffering the mental illness we we
we we relieve people who have a mental
illness of
responsibility and if you're if you have
a mental illness you have a mental
illness and you know we don't we don't
condemn you morally for it do we want to
take that position with respect to
racism maybe the answer is yes but on
the other hand maybe the answer is no
I'll have to think about that a bit more
but thank you very much for the question
Scott in Toccoa Georgia Scott did I say
the name your town correctly yes you did
Northeast Georgia just about an hour
from Atlanta all right dr. Kennedy uh
thank you for taking my call and about a
decade ago on this very show introduced
to the author Stanley Crouch I was just
curious your thoughts or reflections on
his work as it relates to the
conversation on race yeah well very
quickly and I know Stanley Crouch and I
agree with some positions that he's
taken and I disagree with other
positions that he's taken he has a have
a style of presentation that's different
from my style I mean he is a he's a
columnist
he is self-consciously a pugnacious
polemicist who you know takes a position
and just zeroes in on that as you've
heard over the you know my time on this
show and others I mean I take positions
but I also always make sure to acquaint
the reader with other positions and I'm
perfectly happy in telling a reader the
other position has some good points to
it and I'm perfectly happy to tell a
reader that I'm ambivalent I'm happy to
tell a reader that I'm unsure um so you
know there's just different styles of
presentation my style I think is one
that I think some people see sometimes
it's insufficiently militant with
respect to certain issues but my style
is my style and you know
just has a different style but it's one
respect and I you know I I get a benefit
from reading his material email from
Justin in Pittsburgh Pennsylvania it's
not fair for professor Kennedy to reduce
his being called a sellout to being
simply a response to his being a Harvard
Law professor does he not think he is
playing in part in certain sections of
his books the role of an embedded
reporter for a largely white audience
um I think descriptively there's
something to that statement I am a
reporter to an audience do I think that
my audience is made up largely of white
readers yeah sure I have lots of white
readers I have lots of black readers I
have lots of readers of all sorts that
doesn't bother me at all and so you know
I don't I don't I don't feel bad about
having readers of all different sorts
nor do I feel bad and there's some
people have criticized me but they say
gosh you know you say things which
people are going to use in a bad way
aren't you concerned about that well you
know frankly when you write a book
anybody who writes any book should know
especially if it's about a volatile
political subject you write a book it
really goes out of your hands I write a
book it goes in the bookstores it goes
into libraries people are going to take
the book they're going to run with it
there's some people are going to take
what I've said and go in a completely
different direction that I intended that
I would want I accept that as one of the
hazards that comes with writing I accept
it I try to make myself as clear as I
possibly can at a given point I
recognize that everything I say is to
some extent provisional I send in my
manuscript the book comes out I have
that great pleasure of seeing it I
it usually within two weeks
I'm already revising in our conversation
over the past couple of hours they've
been at least three occasions what I've
said you know if I was writing that now
I would tweak it here I would tweak it
there that's what comes with writing
books and I'm not inhibited by it it
doesn't really it doesn't bother me in a
big way it just comes with the territory
as far as I'm concerned where do you do
your writing and how do you fit that in
with classes I do my writing everywhere
I have three wonderful children
Henry Kennedy fattiest Kennedy Rachel
Kennedy as I as I you know chauffeured
them around to soccer games or football
games or parties and things as I'm
waiting for them in my car I have lots
of paper I I can I can write anywhere
some people can only write one place not
me I write all the time I can write any
time I can write late at night I can
write early in the morning I'm always
writing I write all the time when I'm
teaching I'm writing what I'm not
teaching I'm writing so you know one of
the one of the things that I like about
writing is it's it's something I can do
frankly anytime tell your kids I have
twins that are 13 years old and I have a
17 year old so I'm surrounded by
teenagers they too are a great
encouragement they they hear about they
live with these books as I write them I
test out various portions on them they
see the covers they see the titles they
make suggestions all the time and
sometimes I take their suggestions and
sometimes I don't but they are very
helpful collaborators
the process your first book was
dedicated for my darling wife Yvette
loved a matauri yes I've said many times
in our conversation that I lived a very
charmed life there is one great
exception to that and that was the death
of my wife six years ago
Evette Natori was a wonderful cancer
surgeon she succumbed to a skin cancer
of a disease on which she had done quite
a bit of research and of course that was
a terrible tragedy and and you know it's
still very much a part of my life and I
did dedicate that book to her and she's
still you know very much a part of my
thoughts and the thoughts and love of me
and our children together Richard and
Laredo Texas you're on with Randall
Kennedy well god bless I've heard we
need all the god bless we can get these
days but my suggestion is I have a word
that might help but point out the real
problem we're dealing with me with
racial and ethnic all kind of America
the words of his variational in Spanish
word boudoir Christ yet which means
bureaucracy we trust too much in the
system and the bull drill pulling a
bullock cart is Nate ago you're going to
drag the blue Ricard we'll all be
pleased whichever way it decides to go
so we may think we're in charge but the
Buddha was pulling cars and whichever
way he pulls the car we all we in the
car follow well you know I I think I
probably differ with the caller I think
fortunately we live in a society that
for all of its problems and it has many
done
provide a space to influence our faith
and influence the fate of those to come
and in fact you know one of the ways in
which our society gives us space is
through permitting people to write what
they think and disseminate what they
think it's one of the most important
ways in which we have some influence on
our surroundings and I'm very grateful
to that I don't think it should be taken
for granted at all we need to be very on
guard as to any force that encroaches
upon that but it's things stand one of
the great one of the great glories of
our society is the space given to people
to express themselves and communicate
with their fellows Sondra in Albany
California we have exactly one minute
left for your question and for professor
Kennedy's answer go ahead thank you mr.
Kennedy mr. Kennedy President Obama
addressed APEC today and tomorrow will
be meeting with mr. Netanyahu of Israel
what does it take to have our President
Obama meet with and talk to the black
community who are suffering so badly and
our current recession for the same
seriousness respect and accommodation
what can we do ourselves as a group to
assure our civil rights we have to leave
it there son I think that the president
on an ongoing basis is meeting with
various sectors of the black community I
think it's a mistake to think that he is
you know indifferent to the black
community I think he is very aware of
various problems the black community
faces and that in fact he's doing
what he thinks he can to help black
Americans along with other Americans do
I agree with all of it the president
says no and in my book I'm critical of
him in certain ways but by and large I
think the President of the United States
is doing what he can to advancing
interests of all Americans and that will
have to be the last toward our guest has
been Harvard professor and author
Randall Kennedy race crime in the law in
word the strange career of a troublesome
word interracial intimacy's was his
third book sellout was his fourth and
the persistence of the color line is his
newest book came out last year and
another new book coming out on
affirmative action in early 2013
professor Kennedy thank you for being on
in-depth